Nice work.
In this section, you've learned
what a Progressive Web App is, and
why it's a great solution for
your users.
Whether they're connecting with
a fast fiber connection, or
on a slow 2G connection.
But more importantly, you've started
building a Progressive Web App.
You've used the App Shell model to
separate the app from the content, and
you've weighed the pros and
cons of different storage techniques
to store user preferences like the list
of cities the user cares about.
In the next section, you'll be adding a
service worker to cash your up shell and
the weather forecast data, ensuring
that your app is blazing fast and
works offline.
See you then.